we're going to call this pantyhose
eyeshadow you know the sheer dress Trend
that's everywhere all the celebs are
doing these see-through dresses this is
the makeup equivalent so pantyhose
eyeshadow is like a soft sheer fail of
smoky color similar to see-through
pantyhose it's delicate it's subtly sexy
and it leans a little grungy too a great
example is the sheer smokey eye that
Kylie Jenner did recently to launch her
new classic matte eyeshadow palette she
wore a gray brown see-through dress that
matched it with a gray brown see-through
eyeshadow that showed a little bit of
bare lid beneath it gave like a stocking
sort of finish to create it use matte
finishes over shimmers in Browns blacks
Grays and then diffuse it out for that
15 denier finish so that's it pantyhose
eyeshadow and heading into Autumn we
reckon we'll be seeing a lot more of it